principles out principles until they
cost you
something let's be really honest and
talk about how you viewed feminism the
feminism I was coming across was whether
or not air conditioning was sexist you
know and I felt it was very
trivial hello I'm Julie bindle and this
is action men a series in which I have
interesting conversations with men that
actually get up off their backsides and
contribute to the work feminists are
doing to prevent rape domestic violence
and challenge pornography and the sex
trade this week I'm speaking with
Michael foren who's a lecturer in public
law at the University of Glasgow for the
former Scottish first Minister Nicholas
sturon her downfall came after trying to
push forward the gender recognition act
a dangerous Bill allowing
self-identifying females actually males
to enter womenonly spaces Michael was
behind the movement laying out the legal
framework that was able to bring down
sturgeon's campaign tell me a little bit
about yourself right well I'm a legal
scholar I think it's the best way to
describe it I'm an academic who works in
a university who teaches and researches
on um equality law is my main area of um
interest and expertise um and I suppose
the thing that I'm most known for now is
that I've done a lot of public
commentary on the law in relation to sex
and gender and I came across your work
before I met you so I read that you were
this man
who was in Academia and had dipped his
toe in fact thrown himself in full force
I think to the cesspit that is the issue
about women's sex-based rights and the
threat from the gender ideology of
current so tell me what you think that
you have done
that might actually help us in our
ongoing struggle to maintain those
rights yeah I think the this is kind of
an interesting story because I I didn't
come into this wanting to do something
that would be kind of classed as
activism necessarily um I initially
wrote a short blog post in a specialist
constitutional law blog about the
definition of sex in the equality act
and how that feeds into what at that
point was an ongoing um trajectory of um
legislation through the Scottish
Parliament the gender recognition Reform
Bill which would have introduced self ID
as a as a legal policy into Scotland and
I I just kind of posited a a blog post
that that said that there was a a legal
mechanism here that the UK government
could have relied on if it wanted to to
block this bill um and the reason why it
could have blocked that bill was because
the bill was going to have adverse
impacts on the operation of of equality
law specifically as that relates to uh
women and girls um and also and
particularly communities like Muslim
women or or Orthodox Jewish women um and
so I I I posited that and the bog post
happened to be published on the second
day of the reading of the bill in the
Scottish Parliament and so then within a
few hours this had been picked up and it
was um cited on the floor of the
Scottish Parliament by Pauline mcneel
and at that point things went into a
direction I didn't think they were they
were going to go into things really they
took off and I decided I was going to
double down so I had a very busy
Christmas my family were checking in and
handing me plates of dinner while I was
writing this big long um piece and the
the basically the the paper was uh the
argument in favor of blocking this bill
the reason why the bill and the policies
related to it would cause conflicts of
rights that could have a much wider
impact outside of Scotland as well and
would have touched upon reserved areas
that the the UK government and um part
ment as a whole might want to be
consulted on so these conflicts of
Rights obviously they're between women
and those men that identify as trans
women yeah so legally this is a is a
really difficult framework and one of
the things that we have uh a difficulty
and a confusion at the moment is just
how in law are we defining the category
of woman um what what does sex mean in
law that's become really really
complicated and really really contested
lately and but one thing that was clear
in the law up until this bill was coming
in was that it was not on the basis of
self ID um you couldn't just declare
yourself to be a member of the opposite
sex and then legally be treated as a
member of the opposite sex what you did
have in law were protections for people
on the basis of what's referred to as
gender reassignment which basically
means if you're proposing to undergo you
are undergoing or you have undergone a
process or part of a process of changing
aspects of your sex so physiological
aspects of your sex or other kinds of
aspects of your sex you're protected in
discrimination law so you can't be fired
for this so if um someone was going
through a process of medical transition
or something like that and they told
their employer they were doing that they
they couldn't be fired for that which of
course feminists have always supported
we shouldn't discriminate against people
because of the way they live their lives
in the sense that they live as the
opposite sex it started to get very
difficult didn't it when trans activists
started to say we are women we are
female we will enter the spaces and we
don't agree with exemptions we've seen
many an example of how the female
bathrooms in public buildings have been
made into the
non-binary the either sex either
whichever gender and the men's have
remained the men's and that's outrageous
discrimination isn't it yeah this would
be what
would we we normally called this
indirect discrimination so this is what
looks like a neutral rule they've
converted some of the toilets into um
into gender neutral toilets but it
actually has a disproportionately
negative effect on U one group over
another and actually in this context um
if you had kept the men's toilets the
same and had converted the women's
toilets only and the reasons that you
can imagine someone would be thinking
about what this would be well we want
cubicles we don't want to have to deal
with urinal so it's easier if we just
convert the the spaces that have already
just got cubicles and that's sail into
account for the fact that what you've
done there is you've treated women less
favorably than you've treated men
because you've removed um something from
them and you've not removed it from men
so it could be direct discrimination in
that context but if let's say you you
all you did instead was to just make all
of your toilets gender neutral um and
what I mean by gender neutral toilets
there is is not creating a separate
space that we class as a gender neutral
toilet that people can use but
converting existing spaces into mixed
sex bases that's not going to have as
much of a negative impact upon men it's
a neutral rule you've converted all of
your toilets to gender neutral toilets
but the people who are
disproportionately affected by that are
going to be women they're going to be
Muslim women they're going to be
Orthodox Jewish women they might also be
Muslim and Orthodox Jewish men as well
um but on the whole the people who um
suffer from that are going to be women
and that's what's going to give rise to
the kinds of indirect discrimination
concerns that we'd be interested in as
as as equality lawyers so the point
about thinking about these kinds of
questions from the perspective of
equality law is to bear in mind that
equality law is an ecosystem you have to
be concerned about how your policies
affect all affected groups um and that
does include being concerned about how
that's going to affect people who are
covered under gender reassignment as
well but it means you can't take a
myopic focus on on all of them um and so
for that reason
the you know I'm interested in this
because some of these policies are
disproportionately affecting women but I
don't don't think I'd see myself coming
at this solely from the perspective of
women's rights conc let's look at your
um focus on the disproportionate effect
on women many of us met you after your
baptism of fire your your blog and I met
you in person a while ago you've
obviously been supportive of
organizations such as LGB Alliance
particularly with the vexatious case
taken against them by mermaids you've
been around and about some of the
circles I move in and it was a real
pleasure to meet you knowing that a man
in Academia what age are you 29 so a man
of your age of your generation in
Academia currently would normally be on
the trans women of women sex work is
work neoliberal side of the fence and
I'm not suggesting that we would agree
on everything in in order of my feminist
beliefs and principles and the like but
you have a very
clearcut notion I would say that women
as a sex class are oppressed by men as a
sex class but has this brought you into
new territories I mean talking to the
likes of me and getting involved in what
is a very very painful and bitter time
for feminists and has been for some
years because of the gender IDE ology
and capture of Institutions and the like
yeah I I I think this has been a real
learning experience for me in a number
of ways that you don't really exper you
particularly as a man I think you don't
really know if you've if you've if
you've gone through the experience of it
um I didn't know how much I didn't know
about this topic until I wrote something
about it not really thinking about it
from the perspective of like I've been
following these debates but I'd not been
thinking it from within the perspective
of the groups that might be uh affect by
it um and and one thing I I did notice
the more that I got into it was
how little I knew about this topic even
as a lawyer like I there are a lot of
expert lawyers who will know the law
about a particular area but won't know
it in the level of depth because we're
kind of generalists particularly if
you're a generalist equality lawyer
you're not going to be that focused on
it and so some of the stuff that I would
have come across was seeing in
particular women who have been writing
about this topic for years years and
years and years who know more about this
topic than most other people just being
dismissed um and their views not taken
seriously um and you we you know we saw
this in in in policy arguments and we
saw this you know the the cast example
now that's becoming Infamous as Nicholas
sergeon saying that these concerns are
not valid and um we've now had
politicians say that you know it's all
just a bunch of 50-year-old Karens which
is both misogynistic and agist but what
you've also seen what I've also seen as
well is that the backlash although I did
get significant backlash and continue to
get um you know this is a very heated
very toxic debate I think and there are
people on all sides of the the the
arguments that have uh kind of fueled
those those flames in particular ways
but one thing I've absolutely noticed is
that had I been a woman this would have
been a lot worse the the kinds of
experiences that I have had in terms of
kind of push back and critique and
things like that um I've not got
sexualized threat nobody has threatened
to rape me nobody has threatened to um
to assault me nobody has spoken down to
me in a way you know i' I've benefited
both from being an academic and from
being a male academic I think and seeing
in particular um discrimination lawyers
you know who will I I will say for
example I I think I tweeted saying
something along the lines of I think
this would have been a lot different had
I been a woman and then a disc a female
discrimination lawyer that that I know
who's been writing about this for years
Audrey Ludwick who's brilliant um quote
tweeted that and said yes that's
probably true and then she got a whole
host of misogynistic abuse as a result
of it it was just proved its point in a
way that I did not experience um so it's
been a real learning experience for me
um and I think this is the kind of stuff
that you you know you're constantly
changing your views on on this and I
know you know when I was when I was a
lot younger 10 years or so I would have
been approaching questions around
feminism from a very skep iCal
perspective and I think I've really
moved on a lot since then tell me a
little bit about that if you would
Michael the 18 19 year old 20y old self
and what feminism meant to you then so
we're talking about what 20134 that that
era and obviously the gender ideology
was already alive and well but about to
reach a new
Peak what would you have said about
feminist like me let's be really
honest um and and talk about how you
viewed feminism at that time and how it
shifted and how you view it now well I
think part of the reason why I had the
views that I I had back then which would
have been skeptical of some of the kind
of philosophical claims that are made
from within feminism like the idea of
patriarchy would have been predominantly
because I had not been introduced to the
kinds of what I would see as a very
distinctly British feminist approach um
my critique at that time the things that
I was concerned about was how um
feminism As I understood it which I
think was a predominately American type
of feminism wasn't particularly
concerned about class um and in
particular the kinds of um experiences
that workingclass men would have um
dealt with I've come from a
working-class background um so I would
have grown up and I would have seen um
people who I would have known as like
uncles and you know my father spent 10
years of his life Mixing concrete blocks
with his hands it was a really tough job
to do and you're hearing stories about
how
um the exclusion of women from the
workplace in the you know throughout the
the the scope of History um served to
prevent women from being economically
capable of looking after themselves and
that was obviously true but I I thought
it failed it very much came from the
perspective of a woman who wanted to be
a Barr like her husband and not a woman
who wanted to spend 16 hours a day in a
coal mine like her husband so I had I
had a very critical perspective on that
I thought that was really failing to
encounter that kind of stuff and in
particular I thought you know the kind
of feminism that you do looking at the
most disadvantaged people in society
women who've been raped or trafficked or
who've been subject to the most obscene
forms of
violence the feminism that I was coming
across was not that kind of feminism the
feminism I was coming across was whether
or not air conditioning was sexist you
know and and I felt it was very trivial
really I I'm not going to disagree with
you I mean American feminism has been a
blight on the Grassroots feminist
movement across Europe and the way I
would describe it and I know many
American feminists or feminist based in
North
America that do not fit this bill at all
but they talk about the glass ceiling
they don't talk about the basement they
don't talk about the women in the
basement as the ones that need the most
liberating and I don't mean that we
going to save them but I mean Liberation
from the constraints of their lives I
mean they don't have an opportunity to
leave a violent relationship they don't
have an opportunity to go for an
abortion or to even complain about rape
because they're going to be seen as
worthless as rapable as irrelevant and
unimportant and we see that with murder
victims serial killer murder victims
where these women are just seen as
disposing able and then on the other
hand you've got
some Elite American feminists some of
them within Academia and some of them
just within very wealthy human rights or
NGO organizations where
they
literally are concerned
about somebody earning three4 of a
million dollars as opposed to a million
dollars which her male counterpart is
now we know that's sexism we know that's
discrimination
but why would we care about fighting for
the rights of those women when they're
never going to look at the material
reality of the lives of women that can't
even get a day off to give birth let
alone maternity benefits or rooms in
which they can express milk so that they
don't have to have the
inconvenience of bringing in their Nanny
to work I mean all of those is issues
they're all specific to women they're
all specific to sexism but where's the
prioritizing yeah and I mean I think you
see this this also kind of parses itself
out in some of the debates that we're
seeing now because I can guarantee that
the the people the the the feminists the
activists who were thinking about
something like self ID hadn't even
contemplated women in prison absolutely
that wasn't something that came across
their their desks they were it's an
elitist it's a very very elitist idea
for them because they won't know anyone
in prison and they'll imagine that
they'll never be in prison and they'll
imagine that they would never need to
use the services of a refuge because
they'll have the resources to escape a
violent household through other means so
yes you're right yeah and and I think I
mean part of this is also I've had a
shift in my own thinking about like what
the purpose of politics is and things
like that it made me reassess you know
the those the the feminist sex wars in
the ' 80s these fights between liberal
feminists and radical feminists about
whether or not to support pornography
whether or not to support prostitution
whether or not to call prostitution sex
work and and and things like that and it
seems to me that on the one hand you
have uh a liberal feminist perspective
that says the purpose of feminism is to
give women more choices regardless of
whether they're coerced into those
choices regardless of whether the those
choices are are good for them um and
then the IAL feminist critique that says
the purpose of feminism is to make
women's lives better and that requires
us to think much more substantively
about what a good life and what
crucially a very bad life might look
like yes and also the normative effect
and how that ripples through societies
and affects the most disenfranchised
women on the planet and if we look at
the women in prostitution for example if
we if we look at indigenous women across
Canada if we look at Mari women in
Australia if we look at um black women
in the US women in poverty and who've
come out of care in the UK all of those
examples are all of women with the least
choice in their lives ending up in
prostitution what a surprise and then of
course you've got the very women that
have the most choice in life and many of
these women are in Academia saying but
sex work is work and how dare you remove
the choice from women to do that and the
men are invisible in this so the punters
the sex buyers the Johns whatever you
want to call called them they're
laughing they're the Invisible Man
because of course the prostituted woman
or the proud sex worker whichever way
you look at it is held up as a smoke
screen for him he he he's just not in
the picture and we tend not to talk
about the men who have the most Choice
doing that to women who have the least
choice I mean has your has your view
shifted on that over the years yeah no I
think it has and I think one of one of
the things that shifted as well is I
think I've moved away from what you'd
see is a liberal or a neoliberal
perspective on this which seems to
operate from the kind of perspective
that we are all wholly self-contained
autonomous whole individuals that are
not really influenced by the society
around us and make our all of our
choices entirely free from it the
influences of culture um into
understanding that we are not apolitical
we are not asocial there's no such thing
as the as the human that exists free
from the society that they're in and if
you think about it from that perspective
and then you think about something like
prostitution pornography these kind of
things it it's you could have a
normative argument about whether they're
good or not but you can't deny that
they're going to have an effect on the
Norms that exist within society and we
we see this in the context of teenage
girls now who think that being choked
during sex is something that is expected
of them is something that is desirable
for them and it's resulting in them
being abused and in some cases even
being killed um and they're getting that
they're not getting that from you know
reading feminist pamphlets about how sex
work is empowering they're not getting
that from um thinking to themselves in
an ivory Tower what would be the best
kind of sexual gratification I could
ever get they're absorbing it from the
culture around them and so the
importance of culture is something that
I've shifted on as well and the idea
that we're we really are embedded in an
existing normative world and you can't
escape that so you have to deal with it
and I think that's the same thing is
true for contexts like um
Muslim women or or is um Orthodox Jewish
women um you know in an Ideal World you
might think we don't want to have um
women wear head scarves we don't want to
have women in contexts where they're
being separated but in the world that
we're in we have to deal with the fact
that these women do exist and that they
do believe these things and they find
deep spiritual satisfaction from those
and they're not going to alter their
behavior in the way that people expect
like the example of banning head scarves
anybody who thinks Banning headscarves
in public means that Muslim women who
wear head scarves are going to take
their heads scarves off when they go
around in public as just fooling
themselves and it ignores the fact that
those women are not choosing to wear a
headscarf from an absolute open vacuum
of free choice there is a stigma upon
those women that don't wear head scarfs
I know that there are women who think of
it as a to the west and I'm going to put
on a head scarf and I'm going to make a
point and I'm going to look visibly
Muslim I know that those women exist but
largely women who AV veiled do so
because that is required of them and we
know about modesty and we know about the
requirements for women to be modest
within religious cultures and outside of
it but I've always thought and often
said that if men on mass and in
particular the kind of young middle
class entitled men
like a particular form of feminism as is
being presented such as walk and
sex work is work and trans women and
women then there must be something wrong
with it because a feminism that
challenges men and that men understand
men that are serious about being on the
side of women fighting to end all these
Horrors men understand that you lose
some of your privilege and your power
and your control
we absolutely do in as a as a white
person in South Africa I was very aware
that if I wanted to challenge myself and
behave properly during that trip that it
was going to be a little bit more
difficult for me than it would have been
had I just gone along with the culture
that lorded me as something special in
that country and I think for men to
say men like o in Jones Billy Bragg to
say most feminists disagree with you
what they mean mean is that most women
that have absorbed these anti-feminist
tropes disagree with us it's not and I'd
love to know what you think of this it's
not enough to Simply adopt the label a
feminist you have to actually do
feminism and believe in a particular
stun by a particular set of aims and
objectives I don't mean rules and I
don't mean membership cards but there
has to be a basis to every single
political movement doesn't there yeah I
mean two things I might say from that
one of them is that your principles
aren't principles until they cost you
something um that there's nothing that
you if your principles happen to always
work out in your favor every single time
then they're not principles you're just
finding ways to rationalize what's in
your
self-interest um so the the real test
for whether or not you're true to your
principles is exactly the point at which
it becomes something that you have to
sacrifice something for that's the point
which they move away from being simply
the way you operate in the world into
being genuine constraints on your
conduct um but secondly I think I mean
you know the example here of um you know
the majority of women um or the majority
of the people who
uh are thinking about these kinds of
questions from a a a pro trans rights
perspective and again this is this is
the thing that I think language is
really important here because that
operates from the presumption that um
people who are concerned about the
tensions between those rights don't want
trans people to have rights at all um
but let's say you see know people who
people who support something like self
idea as a
policy one story you can tell about that
is to say um yes the majority of the
people who support that policy are women
but the majority of the people who
oppose that policy are also women the
real story here is the conspicuous
absence of men in this conversation at
all and and part of that is I think um
because at that point you know men are
just not generally don't tend to be very
interested in things that predominantly
affect women um one way or the other and
part of that I think is that you know
again part of that kind of story that
was um told about
the kind of different waves or
trajectories of kind of feminist
advocacy there was a very long time when
men were effectively told if you're not
a part of this conversation then don't
talk about it and I think some of them
said great I don't have to talk about it
and I won't yeah I think that was a bit
of an own goal the um okay so you
can't say things get them wrong be
kicked up the ass and get back on with
it you just have to be silent and it
it's reminiscent of I mean I suppose the
the kind of new wave of that uh
philosophy is shut up sit down read a
book which is awful yeah and everybody
gets things wrong or really
learns that maybe that wasn't right how
I thought about that but I now think
more clearly about it and have
conversations with people that's a much
more civilized way to get through the
the nightmare that is any political
perspective or philosophy isn't it yeah
I mean I think there's a there's a real
dir of forgiveness in politics um and
you know the idea that you can look at
someone and somebody says I thought
about this and I was wrong um that
that's it's almost impossible to hear
someone say that now because it's not
going to do them any good in in in many
contexts they' already been judged yeah
or they say it such as the recent
example of the theater director in
Scotland who was told off for liking a
couple of tweets one of which by Co
instance was mine very kind of oh
terrible I should never have done that
very you know ordinary
call out for can you give me some
information about an article I'm writing
everybody on Twitter and he just rolled
over and abjectly apologized capitulated
and it was and humiliated himself that
that wasn't an apology he didn't need to
give an apology it it was it was a kind
of please please please forgive me
because I know that otherwise the
bullies will come after me forever and
he's not going to he's just going to
shut down now yeah I mean very often
what happens there is and this this one
of those things where the online world
is very different from the the inperson
world like in person if someone had said
that there's a very real chance that
even people who really really don't like
that person will respond and say okay
well we'll we'll deal with you as a
person but but online the the the
framework gets very different and so the
second you start doing something like
that the the consequences that things
double down and I think you saw this I
mean there's slight parallels to be had
between what happened to Kathleen stock
and and an experience that I had so you
know Kathleen stock is effectively
handed out of her University and part of
that is because at the start of all of
this her University and even her Trade
union made uh noises to the effect of
she kind of deserves this um apologizing
for defending her I mean her Trade union
said that she had weaponized her
employment rights which I'm sorry if
you're a Trade union and you're
concerned about people weaponizing
employment rights you're in the wrong
business um but leaving that aside the
consequence of that was that it got
worse and it got progressively worse for
Kathleen it got to the point where she
had to have police prote she was not
safe on campus she now basically has
police protection pretty much everywhere
she goes and part of that was because
people initially capitulated now I don't
think I'm anywhere near in the same
league as the the kind of influence that
Kathleen stock has had or the kind of
not prety that she's gotten but after
writing about the legal questions that
we and a lot of the stuff I've been
writing is just attempts to clarify the
law there's a lot of misinformation
floating around about what legal rights
people have in this sphere um there was
an attempt by some people to kind of
drum up a campaign to get me fired from
my University um and and I think people
had really learned from the Kathleen
stock incidents because not only did my
University very quickly reassure me that
I was not in any danger there was also
very very public support from senior
colleagues and from um professors and uh
and other academics at other
institutions coming out very very
vocally and I think some of that was
just a genuine commitment from people
who are working in my field to um defend
academic freedom but I think some of it
will be people who might have felt
guilty about not doing the same thing
when it happened to Kathleen Stark
and felt actually you know we've we've
learned some lessons from that um and
the result of it was that it just
stopped it went away I mean the second
if if this kind of campaign starts and
then people start capitulating and
saying well maybe we'll start
investigating this person maybe we'll
look into whether or not person has
actually engaged in um you know the
claims that were being made was that I
was unsafe to be around students because
I was accurately please um and so yeah
this was but but but the consequence of
this was that it was quickly shot down
and then it stopped it didn't happen
again um and I think that's the
consequence of you know people in
institutions who have the capacity it
doesn't cost them very much to be brave
on this to to stand up and say you know
I had a I had a very senior colleague
Professor Adam Tomkins who's the chair
of constitutional law at Glasgow who
very publicly said you come for Michael
you come for me um and that's the kind
of solidarity and support that Kath do
did notet and I think it there's there's
a real consequence I'm still in Academia
and she's not now Michael you said that
your views have changed on feminism in
the last decade let me ask you something
did you ever consider feminist like me
to be manh
haters yes um and I think part of that
is from the political defense of man
hating that you get from within certain
groups of feminist scholarship and I'm
thinking particularly you know Valerie
sanis is the society for cutting up men
the scum Manifesto things that you know
and at the time when I was a petulant
awful teenager you imagine imagine me
but as a law student who thinks he's
right um nightmare absolute nightmare um
so I'm looking at that stuff and I'm
thinking this isn't a movement for
equality here this is this is something
that's um driven by some kind of hatred
or Revenge Revenge well so this is the
thing that I think I've moved on
um hatred can be uh well hatred maybe is
the wrong word but anger can be very
insightful it can be a source of
knowledge um you
can you can dismiss anger too much
within particularly scholarship or
Academia or kind of highbrow society
that if someone is angry they're not
thinking clearly and in fact I think in
in a lot of contexts if you're not angry
you're not thinking very clearly there's
a lot of contexts where anger is the
only appropriate response that you can
have to certain forms of Injustice and
so thinking about that learning that as
a way of kind of thinking about this has
really kind of reframed some of the the
way that I thought about that and I
think the way I think about it now is um
and I always thought it was completely
understandable for women who've been the
victims of male violence to hate the men
who've been violent towards them and
then always thought that extrapolating
that to men as a group was illegitimate
or
unfair
but and so and maybe the hatred maybe
extrapolating the hatred is unfair but
the anger is not I don't think I think
extrapolating anger at the failure of
men to act um to prevent these kinds of
harms is apt um but I think there is a
danger in there because it anger can be
very enticing as well it can be
addictive it it can make you feel
righteous it can can lead to people
having inapt anger anger that's
disproportionate to the the scale of
what is being addressed so the kind of
anger that you might have over whether
air conditioning is sexist um that is
probably a little bit too much anger for
the scale of the issue um when you're
not also equally being vocally angry
about women who are being abused and
beaten and raped and and destroyed but
have you enjoyed meeting feminists and
making new feminist friends oh it's been
great I've Loved this we are the best
aren't we oh absolutely yes and you were
very very good at making fun of me which
I which I very much appreciate as
[Music]
[Applause]
well